Уже рік тут ніхто не мешкає.
Це село на березі річки Ар, від якої ніхто не чекав біди.
Але річка вийшла з берегів і призвела до руйнівної повені.
Як ви думаєте, коли тут, у Шульді?..
Через десять років, через десять років.
Тоді знову буде все гаразд?
Так, ми думаємо, ми сподіваємося.
Особливо сильно постраждала село Шульд.
У липні минулого року через сильні зливи рівень води в невеличкому Арі
піднявся до 7 метрів. Річка перетворилася на бурхливе річище,
що змітало зі свого шляху машини, будинки, мости.
Жертви нарікають, що людей не попередили завчасно і що це стало фатальною помилкою.
Юлія Генріхс рятувалася на даху - з трьома дітьми.
Тут стояв ще один будинок. Фасад обрушився під час повені,
і в ньому ще було двоє людей.
Вони ледь вижили. Будинок її батьків залишився стояти,
незважаючи на величезну дірку в стіні.
Після восьми місяців ремонту вони знову змогли оселитися тут.
Але люди досі не можуть прийти до тями.
Люди бояться води, тож навіть прийняти душ страшно.
Чуєш, як вода ллється з душу, цей шум, це відчуття, що вода скрізь…
Щонайменше 180 людей загинули внаслідок повені століття.
Сотні людей тривалий час вважалися зниклими безвісти, зокрема й у цьому районі.
Я цього ніколи не забуду. Двері, напевно, луснули від напору води,
і дитина просто закричала: "Мамо, допоможи! Мамо, допоможи!"
І раптом стало тихо. І я три дні нічого не бачила і не чула про цих людей,
а потім я побачила їх і зрозуміла: вони в безпеці, з ними нічого не сталося.
Кадри з місця трагедії.
Гори уламків та бруду - багато метрів заввишки.
DW тоді поспілкувалася з Мохаммедом Абдулхамідом, який намагався винести те,
що ще можна було врятувати з його перукарні.
Я тут вже майже шість років - і я втратив все.
Кілька місяців він стриг своїх клієнтів на вулиці.
Декілька днів тому салон нарешті знову відкрився.
Так, слава Богу, але все одно багато чого ще бракує.
Так, звичайно, але на це пішло чимало часу.
Одинадцять місяців!
Я абсолютно щасливий, що салон знову працює, що нормальне життя
повернулося, що зможу знову бачити своїх клієнтів.
Якщо чесно: моє серцебиття пришвидшується від щастя.
Але історія Мухаммеда - виняток.
У багатьох будинках майже нічого не змінилося після повені.
Деякі з них під загрозою обвалу, і неясно, хто платитиме за ремонт.
Лише в небагатьох мешканців була страховка. Частина державної підтримки
не дійшла чи виявилася недостатньою. Серед місцевих існує велике невдоволення,
багато хто очікував кращої підтримки.
Я думаю, що на початку було занадто мало людей або вони не приходили.
А потім ще потрібно було - я думаю, у тебе було те саме -
спочатку підрахувати збитки, потім знайти компанію, яка цим займеться, і таке інше.
У нас була компанія з-за кордону.
Робочих місць у постраждалому регіоні теж поменшало.
Маріо - медбрат, його клініка досі не до кінця відремонтована.
Я працюю неповний робочий день.
Подивимося, як усе піде далі. Я сподіваюся, що клініка відкриється цього року,
але ми не маємо жодної інформації.
Трохи вище за річкою стоять кілька крихітних будинків - "тайні хаус".
Тут зараз мешкають приблизно 30 сімей.
Вони сподіваються, що незабаром зможуть виїхати з тимчасового житла
та повернутися додому.
Дві спальні, одна менша,
тут кухня, а тут вітальня та їдальня.
Міхаель та його родина зможуть незабаром залишити цей міні-будинок.
Майже через рік їхнє затоплене житло нарешті відремонтували.
Але чоловік не знає, чи залишиться він там.
Я думаю, все йде до того, що ми не залишимося там у середньостроковій
чи довгостроковій перспективі.
Я не те щоб відчуваю страх, але це якесь неприємне відчуття.
Якщо зараз десь іде сильний дощ або ось два тижні тому було штормове попередження
- ми відразу починаємо нервувати.
Ар, невинна на перший погляд невелика річка,
за одну ніч змінила життя німців.
І нині, через рік, люди й досі борються з наслідками цієї катастрофічної повені.